[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it
hey everybody I'm Joshua Fields Milburn
welcome to a special edition of ask the
minimalists live as you'll notice I am
solo today Ryan and I just finished up
recording a really great podcast about
friends which will be in your podcast
feed soon so if you don't already
subscribe to our podcast you can find
that over at our website the minimalists
comm or on itunes google play or pretty
much wherever you check out podcast it's
also coming pretty soon to the NPR one
app which we'll be able to find it over
there it's kind of like Pandora for
podcasts in a way anyway I'm going to
answer some questions for you Ryan
couldn't attend this live session so
it'll just be me solo while he's off
with a mentoring client but I want to
answer your question so go ahead and
start asking questions I have plenty of
answers for you and as you start typing
those out I'll just let you know that
Ryan and I are coming to a bunch of
cities this year we're calling it the
less is now tour and what we're doing is
we are presenting a talk an in-depth
talk about minimalism and a bunch of
different cities we've got a brand new
presentation we've got we were reworking
some old material into some new material
and a brand new presentation but we're
also bringing a live version of our
podcasts to a bunch of different cities
we already announced the first city it's
Boston on April 15th that's at the
Wilbur theater tickets to that are
selling out really quickly but we're
announcing a bunch of other cities in
the coming weeks you can find all the
details to that at the minimalists comm
slash tour and while you're there you
can sign up for our email newsletter to
be the first to be notified of new
cities as we announce them alright let's
answer some of your questions here on
Instagram live all right I see a bunch
of first off so I see a bunch of
questions here a bunch of hey come to my
city come to my city thank you thank you
for your support so much
I won't be answering any geographical
questions at this point but we will be
coming to a bunch of city city stay
tuned for that how can I live with a non
minimalist who likes to keep everything
well I think what you need to look at is
what are your values and instead of
seeing where you are different let's try
to find out what your commonalities are
first and ask yourself do I have the
same values as this person and you very
well might have the same values and what
happens is you just have different
interests or different beliefs from that
person and then the question is instead
of trying to drag them to your side of
the aisle how can we try to a meet in
the middle but be how can I show them
the benefits of living a more meaningful
life there are few ways to do that one
is you can simply introduce the question
how might your life be better with less
and by asking that question you can help
them identify what the benefits of
minimalism might be for me initially
that was regaining control of my
finances because I had a massive amount
of debt in fact if you go back and
listen to the finances podcast that Ryan
and I just recorded it's up in your
podcast feed right now that was my
biggest benefit was regaining control of
those finances because I made really
good money in the corporate world but
spent even better money and so I had to
develop a plan and simplify in my life
including the external clutter what was
the first step but then I uncovered all
of these other benefits as well I was
able to regain control of my time which
was really nice because that time
allowed me to start focusing on what I
was passionate about or allowed me to
contribute to my community in a
different way it allowed me to grow in
ways I hadn't been growing before
because I was less focused on the stuff
that I surrounded myself with and I was
able to start looking inward because I
believe that our material possessions
are a physical manifestation of what's
going on inside us quite often that's
internal clutter emotional clutter
spiritual clutter mental clutter and
even financial clutter which stresses us
out right we get really stressed about
our money but the weird thing is once I
simplified my life I walked away from
the corporate world eventually once I
paid off my debts and I made appreciably
less money about 90% less money after
walking away from the corporate world
but I was actually more financially
secure because I made enough money I
made about $23,000 a year
which is not very much money obviously
and I'm not against money I think if you
want to earn a lot of money then by all
means go out and do it I'm not telling
you what to do or what to make I'm just
letting you know that money doesn't help
you buy better habits right once we
improve our habits then the money just
accentuates those habits and now
whenever I do have the opportunity to
make more money I'm able to do much
better stuff with that money I'll give
an example so Ryan and I are headed to
Boston in a few weeks or a couple months
I guess and we took all the presale
tickets from that event and and donated
that money to build an orphanage on the
us-mexico border and that's because I
have that habit of contribution built in
now and so finances it was a big benefit
regaining control of my time
contributing what's the benefit for you
and then what's the benefit for your
partner the people that you live with
help them uncover those benefits instead
of just simply showing them the actions
here's here's what you're supposed to do
no no no no show them why they're
supposed to do it everyone knows how to
declutter their calls it most people
don't know why it's beneficial to
embrace a more minimalist lifestyle all
right what other questions do we have
what has been the most valuable thing
learned on your minimalist path you know
I was hard for me to really let go of my
identity early on one of the first
things we ask someone when we meet
someone new is what what do you do and I
think that's one of life's most
dangerous questions I think we don't
mean anything bad by it when we ask that
question but quite often what happens is
we end up reciting the title that's on
our business card and the problem with
me is I had I had an impressive job
title I was a director of operations for
a hundred and fifty retail stores which
meant I was all sensibly successful I
had a good answer to your question what
do you do but wouldn't you when you
expand out and look at that question
more broadly what do you learn well that
question really means what do you do I
do all kinds of stuff I go to concerts I
like long walks on the beach I I like
spending time with my friends and family
I like a lot of alone time I like
reading I do a lot so what we're really
asking is where do you work how much
money do you earn so I can compare you
to me
on the the socio-economic ladder and I
think it's a pernicious question because
of its implications right and so I found
for me that flipping that question
around instead of saying here's what I
do to earn a paycheck because by the way
there's nothing wrong with earning a
paycheck right what I was able to do is
say I'm really passionate about writing
and even when I was in the corporate
world I told people when they said what
do you do I would flip it around I say
I'm really passionate about writing and
then I'd say what are you passionate
about and it would totally change the
direction of our question and we started
talking about things that we cared about
about creativity or about the the things
that we pursued as hobbies or things we
were interested in doing in our futures
and it allowed us to talk about our more
ideal selves instead of the the self
that we have put ourselves into someone
asked was my partner Rebecca was she a
minimalist before we met yeah I think so
I think maybe not as much of a
minimalist but I never went to her and
said hey I need you to become more of a
minimalist what she saw when she met me
were some of the benefits that I was
experiencing in in my own minimalist
journey and she said wow I could use
some of those benefits as well and so I
think minimalism is not a destination
right minimalism is simply the tool they
get you to help help you get where you
want to go by clearing the path of the
excess stuff so it's not like you own
your 1,000 things or your 100 things and
now all of a sudden you are a minimalist
no you have to keep going as your life
changes because the things that add
value to my life today may not add value
tomorrow and so I have to keep
reevaluate in my life in fact this month
February 2017 Bex and I have been
playing the 30-day minimalism game which
actually 28 days this month because it's
the the shortest month of the year
we're playing the 30 day minimalism game
over it actually together as a family so
it's me and Beck's and Ella our three
year old and what what we're learning
from that is by playing that together is
even though we've radically simplified
our lives there are still things that we
can start to question we can question
the things in our life now and look at
it in a new light so even as a
minimalist or as a minimalist family we
can continue
to question the things that we have the
things that added value in yesteryear
are going to be different today and the
same thing with Ella I mean she's three
years old the things that had a value to
her life at two which was a third of her
life ago are gonna be different now and
so we have to keep questioning those
things in our life and if they if they
aren't serving a purpose if they aren't
bringing us joy in some way then we have
to be willing to let go of those things
so we can make room for either new
things or more important new experiences
and make room for our values so that we
can grow how do you manage when you feel
mentally tired or overwhelmed well I'm a
person who tends to get stressed out
quite a bit
and so overwhelmed certainly resonates
with me but for me that overwhelm or
anxiety or stress is is really a warning
sign that something is wrong
usually that that something means that
I'm too busy I've said yes to too many
things so how do i combat about that
well two things one is I will say no a
lot more now and it's not just saying no
for the sake of saying no but we all
have the same 24 hours in a day so we
have to be really really careful about
what we're saying yes to because if I
say yes to something that is less
important that means I probably have to
say no to something that is more
important to me and I ran into this trap
all the time throughout my 20s whether
it was in the corporate world and I was
saying yes to every networking event yes
to every hangout or buddy or executive
who asked me to spend some time with
them I forsook the most important things
in my life the people closest to me I
forsook my creativity I was an aspiring
writer for a very long time but I didn't
do much writing is all that really meant
I aspired every single day to write but
I didn't get much done because I was
saying yes to the wrong thing so now I
say no a lot more but I'm saying yes to
the most important things when I'm doing
that and the second I prepare a lot as a
inherently anxious person you may want
to go back and listen to our podcast we
did recently about stress it was a
really good episode because Ryan and I
are a lot different when it comes to
stress he thrives
in a stressful environment I remember
back in the corporate world toward the
end of the month when when the stress
was really on that's when he sort of had
his his peak performance he would
perform really well under stress for me
I really want to prepare so I now these
days I go out of my way to prepare
things way in advance if we're gonna
record a podcast next week I will I'll
start preparing a week in advance quite
often and Ryan will be preparing the
morning of he'll wake up two hours early
and prepare that morning for the podcast
we're going to record and it puts him in
a better state and so understand more
about yourself understand more about
your personality are you an introvert or
an extrovert do you are you a planner or
do you thrive more in the moment and
these these personality traits will help
you identify what happens when you get
anxious for me anxious is just a sign
that something needs to change
someone here says in regards to people
how do you go about saying no well
simply you can just say no I mean I
think first off but then for the people
that really care about me and I care
about them they understand that I'm
saying no because I've set an
expectation in advance right they know
me really well because I've done a good
job of setting those expectations so
before they asked me for something that
is by an area that has a yes-or-no
answer that they know to come to me with
that request knowing that I might likely
say no because I've done a good enough
job over the years of letting people
know that I am going to say yes to only
the things that are most important to me
and so when I do say no I can also go to
them and say the reason I'm saying no to
this is blank it's so I can say yes to
one two and three and that's why I'm
unable to do your podcast interview or
that's why I'm unable to travel travel
to your city to do a a speaking gig or
whatever you know Ryan and I we do
speaking gigs we tend to do one a month
at different organizations and
nonprofits we're going out to UCLA and
about a month or so we're going to a a
business association next month but when
we say yes to those things it means
we're saying no
to something else and so when I say no
to someone I could say I have to say no
to this because I accept only one of
these or I have a certain limitation
that I put on myself I put up boundaries
that are empowering not disempowering
boundaries but boundaries that help
guide me toward what my values are
someone says should I move to Missoula
you know I can't really answer that for
you it's really up to you to determine
what are your values where do you want
to be the winters here are brutal I I
moved here in in the summer time
initially and the best summers you could
ever hope for are in Montana it's
absolutely gorgeous it's very low
humidity and the nature here is
absolutely stunning the winters are long
and gray and cold and it's really hard
to travel out of here as well I could
tell you a long term I don't imagine
myself continuing to be in in Missoula
and perpetuity and and when I graduate
from Missoula I'll find the place that
is ideal for that time of my life I
spent the first 31 years of my life in
Dayton Ohio and people often get
surprised when I tell them that if it's
not my favorite city it's in my top two
or three favorite cities and it's
because it's a unpretentious town and
they're sort of very blue-collar and
industrial and the people there I love
the people and Dayton Ohio and and they
make a really great community but I also
felt like at age 31 when I left there
four years ago it was time for me to
graduate and experience something else
in life I don't want to be stuck in one
place forever and so I also value one of
my minor values is mobility I certainly
value being mobile and being in the
relationship I'm in now with Beck's and
Ella Ella's biological father still
lives in in Missoula Montana and so
because of that I am I'm somewhat
tethered to to the city right now but I
still have the opportunity to travel a
lot and have the opportunity to
experience different places
realizing that on a long enough timeline
everything is temporary now when I
consider about moving to a different
place usually the question is like how
long do I want to be there when I first
came out to Montana for example Ryan and
I came out here for four months and we
didn't live in Mizzou
we lived in a cabin on the side of a
mountain near a little town called
Phillipsburg it was one traffic light
and 3,400 square miles so really middle
of nowhere
the closest town had like four bars and
four churches and that was about it
and and so I can tell you that our
experience there allowed us to finish
our second book it was a book called
everything that remains it's still my
favorite thing that we've ever created
and that experience of being in a cabin
in the middle of Montana winter when it
was negative 28 degrees some days I wake
up and it was that cold all you really
had to do was was right there there was
nothing else that that I could do with
my time and it was a very productive
time we got the first draft of that book
done but then we found ourselves slowly
gravitating toward this community of
Missoula Montana it's a very big small
town right or maybe a very small Big
Town you know it's about a hundred
thousand people in the metro area 67
thousand people in the city proper but
it feels much bigger it's very densely
populated so it's very walkable
especially in the summer I walk to our
office here all the time and in the
summer it's a few miles from one side to
the other because we're surrounded by
mountains we're surrounded by beauty but
we also don't have access to a lot of
the stuff that I'd like to have access
to at this point and so what are your
needs what are your values what are your
beliefs and what is the community you
want to surround yourself with and then
based on that you can identify a really
good place for you to go and realize
that it's not always going to be the the
final destination for you when Ryan and
I moved to Missoula finally we we
realized there was a lot of culture per
capita here a lot of different points of
view and a lot of people who thought
differently from how we thought and Ryan
and I think differently from each other
by the way and that allowed us to grow
and expand in a different way and and
eventually I will move on from this town
and we'll move on somewhere else and I
think I've been fortunate enough that
we've done a lot of traveling that we've
got - we've gotten to experience a bunch
of different communities a bunch of
different cities and I've been so
surprised by some of the amazing
communities that we've gone to places
like San Antonio Texas or st. Petersburg
or Portland Maine or I mean even big
cities like Los Angeles California is
one of my big favorite cities in the
world because there are some amazing
people there their pockets of you and I
know places like Los Angeles they get a
reputation for being you know Hollywood
or whatever but when you have 20 million
people in a place you can use technology
like the Internet to to find these
pockets of amazing people and plus the
weather and places like Southern
California is absolutely amazing and so
that's another thing you have to ask do
what do you value about the weather or
the climate or the geography and and you
know plan accordingly
someone said do you do laundry every day
no man that would that would be so
annoying wasn't it I'm looking over a
podcast Shawn here no I own enough
clothes to get me by for at least a week
probably eight days or so go back and
listen to our clothing episode though
Ryan and I did a really long clothing
episode about sustainable clothing but
also the clothes that we wear personally
and why we wear it and and really how
that aligns with our minimalist
lifestyle as well I think it was episode
58 something like that maybe 56
somewhere in there we did a whole
episode on clothing though it was like
two hours long so I won't rehash all of
that right now Oh Colin right Colin
right on here said take off your shirt
I will not it is cold in Montana so I
will now if you take it off my shirt
Colin I'm sorry disappoint you by the
way my friend Colin he has been on fire
with his podcast lately check it out if
you haven't his my favorite episode of
his just came out this week it it was
called political omnivores and he has a
very balanced measured and unique
approach to looking at politics from a
non ideological perspective and I really
respect him even though he and I differ
politically we lived together for for
seven months so I know that we we differ
on some political aspects we have
similar thought processes about a lot of
things so check out his podcast it's
called let's know things and he explores
a bunch of different topics you
also runs a blog called exile lifestyle
that he was actually the reason that I
became a minimalist so if you want some
inspiration he's he's a good guy to
follow at Colwyn is my name on instagram
by the way do you see a link between
minimalism and spirituality I think
you'd have to define what spirituality
means and I think that word carries a
lot of baggage now and so I have friends
who are spiritual like Sam Harris who is
a really well-known atheist but he wrote
a book called waking up a guide to
spirituality without religion and then I
have other friends who are pastors or
former pastors like Rob Bell and they
identify spirituality as something a
little bit different and I think there's
a lot of overlap between them and so I
think no matter what your spiritual
beliefs are or your religious beliefs or
lack of religious beliefs
I think minimalism can play a part
because it allows you to identify and
then focus on what is important to you
in terms of being more intentional with
your life and aligning your short-term
actions with whatever your long-term
values might be and that that was what
was actually so appealing to me when I
first discovered minimalism I saw Cullen
Wright and everything he owns fits into
his backpack because he travels to a new
country every four months or so and so
he can't own a kitchen table because
that's really hard to get into the
overhead bin of an airplane but then I
saw other minimalist like Eva and Leo
Bob Alta and there are six kids they are
a whole minimalist family you might
remember Leo from our documentary which
is called minimalism and then other
minimalist like Kourtney Carver and her
husband in Salt Lake City or Tammy
Strobel and then more and more
minimalist all these different flavors
of minimalism so no matter where you are
on the political spectrum the
socio-economic spectrum the whether you
are in this country or you're in a
third-world country quite often what
I've learned is that we can all benefit
from being more deliberate with our
actions with our beliefs and by
questioning what really adds value to
our lives that starts with the stuff for
me but then it goes way beyond the stuff
I think getting rid of the clutter is
not the end result it
is merely the first step because then
we're able to go down that path a bit
farther toward toward what we value what
our tips for dealing with people in your
life who don't get minimalism I wouldn't
try to have them get minimalism I don't
think that should be the goal I think
the the benefits should be the goal I
never jumped up and said look at me I'm
becoming a minimalist and you need to as
well I didn't go to my best friend Ryan
I didn't go to people at work but in
time took me about eight months but I
got rid of about 90% of my possessions
in eight months now that might sound
really radical at first but I would
argue that it's practical the average
American household has 300 thousand
items in it according to the LA Times
now of those 300 thousand items if I got
rid of 90 percent what does that mean
how many items do I have left I don't
know I don't actually count my stuff but
did I have 30 thousand items left ten
thousand why I don't know I don't count
my things like that but what I can tell
you is that by getting that stuff out of
the way what I was able to do is change
who I was inside and people at work
started saying things like you know what
you seem so much calmer these days you
seem less stressed or or what's going on
with you you you seemed so much nicer
and that opened up the door for me to
start explaining minimalism as opposed
to me going to them and saying hey guess
what I'm getting rid of all of my stuff
because if I were to say that what would
they say oh you're suicidal
that's the telltale sign of suicide if
someone's getting rid of their stuff or
maybe it's the telltale sign that I'm
actually prioritizing my life for the
first time in my life someone said I
want to be a minimalist but darn it I
just bought a new rug today here's what
I would say does that rug add value to
your life and for those of you playing
the the minimalist drinking game every
time I say add value you're supposed to
take a shot or throw something out
hopefully or not throw something now get
rid of something hopefully in a
responsible way and here's the thing you
bought a new rug doesn't add value does
it serve a purpose or does it bring you
joy I have a rug it's an Ella's room but
I own a rug and I am a minimalist it's
okay that you own a rug if that rug
serves a purpose or brings you joy
great have at it this person here says I
have debt should we pay ourselves first
well I won't I won't beat you over the
head with all of my financial advice go
back to our finances podcast it was
published very recently and then also
check out an essay that I wrote with
Ryan called a financial freedom 5
difficult steps to getting out of debt I
think it's very important to get out of
debt before you start investing in your
future although I like to build that
habit of investing for the future so
what I encourage people who are in debt
to do is start saving $20 a month just
so you start flexing that muscle it's
not gonna yield an actual result for you
other than you're gonna build that
muscle that in time once you're out of
that you can start contributing a lot
more to your retirement you can find
that essay by the way at the minimalists
comm a slash freedom what do you think
about Dave Ramsey I think Dave Ramsey is
great I think he's an inspiration in
fact I used much of his method his book
the Total Money Makeover I used when I
was getting out of debt myself had six
figures worth of debt and I used his
envelope system and his baby step system
to help me get out of debt I want to put
all my video games in the microwave is
this okay yeah I don't think they'll
taste very good heat it up honestly
someone says unfortunately your movie is
not available on German Netflix sorry
about that it is available worldwide on
Vimeo so you can check it out over on
Vimeo just go to minimalism film.com we
are working with Netflix to try to have
an online release worldwide as opposed
to our Netflix release worldwide as
opposed to just the seven or eight
countries that it's in right now so stay
tuned to that if you want to watch it in
the meantime by the way the Vimeo
release is the only place where you can
get the six hours of bonus interviews so
obviously making a documentary we spent
three years making it we had thousands
of hours of footage but we had plenty of
interviews that we've felt really good
about they just couldn't make it into
the film or some of the interviews were
in the film we have extended versions of
those interviews over at the Vimeo
release so minimalism film calm if
you're interested in checking that out
someone here says next tour dates States
the minimalists comm / tour make sure
you're on a newsletter to be the first
to hear about new events what are your
thoughts on nutrition I have a fairly
simple diet you can check out my diet
over at the minimalists comm / diet I
think health is the most underrated
thing that we can change in our lives
and so I used to weigh 80 pounds more
than I weigh now but I wasn't just fat
like I felt like crap and that was a
really problem because it bled over into
every other area of my life whether it
was my work or my relationships or my
creativity just all of my life felt
bloated because I was bloated and that
was a because I didn't exercise but but
more important I just didn't eat very
well I didn't understand nutrition and
then third and just as important is
sleep
I really value my sleep now I'm an early
riser which means I usually go to bed
really early come 6:00 p.m. I'm ready
for bed by 8:00 p.m. I'm generally going
to bed most nights and I like to get up
really early 4 or 5 a.m. but not with an
alarm clock I like to get up when when
my body tells me to get up I find that's
the most productive time of day for me
I'll get up and I'll start writing
really early I'll exercise in the
morning I'll read in the morning and
I'll do my my physical therapy because I
have a really bad back that I've been
healing and and that time in the morning
is by far my most productive time of the
day usually before before anyone else
wakes up right it gives me the
opportunity to sort of be productive
before the rest of the world is even
awake what is your favorite recipe from
minimal wellness.com so my partner
Rebecca Beck's she has a great website
with a blog and a bunch of free recipes
in fact she's doing like I said she her
and I are doing the the 30 day
minimalism game together so at minimal
wellness on Instagram for those of you
are interested in following along with
that 30 day minimalism game what's my
favorite recipe on minimal wellness calm
it is probably anything that she does
with halibut she is a Mozart of cookie
and in general but especially with
halibut every every
thing that she makes it involves halibut
I absolutely love but all the recipes on
there are really healthy nutritious and
I think they're all gluten-free as well
even though she isn't completely gluten
free I am but all her recipes are and
they're really simple too and relatively
easy to make all right here's a good
question to end it on here Sara asks how
do you retrain a young child's
materialistic mindset when your family
is becoming more minimalist well first
thing you need to realize is your kids
are watching you and they're mimicking
and mirroring what you do so what they
do is actually I know this is hard to
believe for most of us because we're
afraid to turn the mirror on ourselves
but what they do is mimetic of what you
do or have done in the past they've
learned that from you or they learned it
from other people but generally they
learn from the adults that they are
closest to and so often Ella is just
mimicking my behavior good or bad now
here's the thing she we have a donation
box in the house and it's really helped
out because she understands the value of
contribution by letting go of something
someone else is going to be able to
start using that thing getting value
from that thing check out at minimal
wellness --is feed this month you'll see
some of the stuff that Ella has
personally donated this month as part of
our 30 day at minimalism game you can
check out the things she's willing to
let go of and sometimes not so willing
to let go of and we have to have
discussions about it then but at the end
of the day I think that we are the
models for them and so instead of simply
mandating sometimes there's room for
that we need to mandate to our kids
obviously but usually they're gonna
learn best if we're modeling that
behavior and the cool thing about that
is it's also true for our friends our
family our co-workers our acquaintances
and everyone else in our life let's not
drag them with us kicking and screaming
toward minimalism let's walk in that
direction show them the benefits and
hope they follow us I hope to see you
all on the road this year Ryan and I are
hitting a bunch of cities make sure you
check out the less is now tour sign up
for email newsletter over at the
minimalists dot-com a slash tour we just
announced the Boston date that's getting
ready to sell
many more cities coming in the coming
weeks thanks for spending this time with
me today if you leave here with just one
message I hope it's this love people and
use things because the opposite never
works thanks for listen y'all I'll see
you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your green oh I bet that you'll be fine
without it
[Music]
every little thing that you gotta have
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for you gotta grab though I
bet that you'll be fine
without your team
[Music]
you
[Music]